non non viktor orban diane gagné haut la
main oui c'est vrai prix le président
serbe vient de gagner haut la main alors
qu'il est très proche de poutine poutine
fait gagner ses alliés ailleurs en
europe et c'est une des raisons qui font
moi je serais très prudent sur l'issue
du du deuxième tour c'est une des
raisons c'est pas la seule il y en a
d'autres je pense que une des premières
raisons c'est que on est dans un moment
historique en sciences politiques on
parle depuis quelques années maintenant
la tripolarisation du champ politique on
y est c'est clair on va arrêter de
parler de la gauche et la droite si vous
voulez bien aujourd'hui ça veut dire
quoi que les partis traditionnels sont
morts pour vous oui ils sont exactement
à l'endroit où les clivages ne
fonctionne plus le ps est coupé en deux
entre tous sur tous les sujets de
société il ya plus de ps et elle est un
coupé en deux sur tous les sujets de
société dès lors pourquoi ils survivent
localement s'il ya une prime aux
sortants et oui ils survivent localement
et il ya une semaine j'étais sur ce
plateau et je vous disais on est dans un
pays quand même étrange où en gros on a
trois forces politiques qui tiennent la
faire au niveau local avec des élus des
milliers d'élus ps ait l'air et eu elle
veut un je vous rappelle quand même que
même une dizaine de maires hellweg
réalise c'est pas négligeable et ses
trois parties sont aujourd'hui à moins
de 5 % seront pas remboursés sont
cessation de paiement pour le dire
rapidement alors
déjà vendus
vous avez suivi les populismes des
années des années ce que vous voyez les
prémices de l'arrivée du rassemblement
national au pouvoir aujourd'hui en fait
ça fait plus d'un an que nous sommes un
certain nombre d'analystes à dire
attention cette fois on est là elle va
pas jouer juste pour être présentes on
est plus en 2002 ça fait 20 ans moi je
faisais ma thèse le 3 mai 2002 et je
disais il pourrait être au second tour
mais c'était entre guillemets c'était
folklorique et puis le soir même à
bastille avait un monde fou et le 1er
mai il y avait un million de personnes
dans la rue regardez en ce moment
mais non seulement elle peut gagner
parce que il ya un effet de report
différentiel et d'abstention
différentiel qui va jouer il ya un effet
de anti macron qui va également se faire
sentir et ensuite je le dis gentiment
mais on a quand même une verrine vécu
une campagne absolument folle une
campagne complètement à droite et à
l'extrême droite ou eric zemmour lièvre
je le disais ici encore aussi il a joué
molière pour marine le pen à la fin il
s'effondre il fait 7 % ce qu'on pouvait
tout se dire sociologiquement il ne
représente rien par contre il a
parfaitement présidentialiser marine le
pen qui elle récupère les marrons du feu
donc oui vous dites 33 % c'est ça en
réalité aujourd'hui on a trois blocs un
bloc conservateur voire réactionnaire
populiste et identitaire un bloc libéral
gestionnaire avec emmanuel macron est un
blog qui n'est pas constitué
politiquement mais que en effet
mélenchon monsieur mélenchon essayer de
constituer on va appeler sociale
écologiste pour faire rapide et ces
trois blocs aujourd'hui ne sont pas
constitués en france ils le sont dans
d'autres pays ils ne sont pas en france
et chacun de ces blocs a réussi ou pas
apporté les réponses aux cinq grave
crise que nous venons de traverser et
malgré ses cinq crises qu'ovide climat
le vaccin le crise sanitaire ukraine à
chaque fois c'est une crise grave sur
les réseaux sociaux c'est la foire
n'importe quoi et on arrive quand même
un deuxième tour macron le pen à la fin
on vraiment rien ne change pour que tout
choix
[Musique]